he was once the world's most famous male
model even his look
leti grrah Magnum and of course blue
steel but that was a long long long time
ago old LeMay we were joking
I miss fashions change leave the biggest
supermom the whole world is all are you
like a male model or a female model all
is all I think he's asking do you have a
hot dog or a bun
Derek Zoolander
I'm with Interpol I need your help she's
hot I trust her
someone's trying to kill the world's
most beautiful people
Oh foot so well all of them died with
your signature look this is Bruce team
right we need you to infiltrate the
world of high fashion we're back
we sure do Landers right now help us
hey handsome
Oh
you were amazing
I'm sorry I can't understand a word that
you're saying uh-huh
Derek go spin tonight you've got it
yeah
there's only one criminal mastermind who
could be behind all this hasn't changed
me
I am bad to the core now
talked where's my goddamn latte but how
am I supposed to stop him got to I'm the
mom of a Jaffa I'm in found by you and
amber you're Derek Zoolander stop the
Chinese throwing star with a look plash
me that beautiful Magnum wait Magnum now
maybe we could try a wash go